jennifer aniston and justin theroux are  separating ET can confirm the pair are  separating after two and a half years of  marriage they released a joint statement  that read in part quote this decision  was mutual and lovingly made at the end  of last year we are two best friends who  have decided to part ways as a couple  but look forward to continuing our  cherished friendship sparks first  ignited while the actors worked on the  2012 comedy wanderlust my first  impression when Jennifer is how  spontaneous she is she's an incredibly  present and hysterically funny actress  and so we had marrying in August 2015  the couple spoke fondly of one another  to ET many times because I just was  watching the way Justin looked at you  while you were taking your picture he  was like oh that's my lady right there  gave you to look like oh yeah she looked  in my what's a compliment that you give  Jen the most she's beautiful not to be  corny but it's true so I can't say that  [Music]